knowing that you wanted to act is that
sort of a fuzzy origin story it was a
sort of a rather sort of uncomfortable
mix of unbelievable vanity they're all
looking at me I love it there's no and
and a righteous love of literature and
storytelling and the world of the
imagination and really so it was a
combination of those two things but I've
my very first role which I remember to
this day I had no lines which is always
a very good thing incidentally not have
any lines but I had a gorgeous costume
good combination
I was playing the Virgin Mary directly
naturally I'm six six I do remember my
costume it was all it was blue with
stars on it so gorgeous and I was so
good at you know paying Virgin Mary I
was taken around from from classroom to
classroom to sort of sitting and I loved
it I absolutely loved it your devotion
towards your career was something that
your passion was instilled early by your
mother - again ahead of her time she was
just sort of very worried that you would
succumb to romance getting married sort
of it get locked in that and that was
never ever your ambition which was also
you're ahead of your time as well was
this all something you knew and carried
with you yes I mean I think we are all
the products about our parents and I was
the product of two of two people both
who really believed in women being
financially independent right and really
believed that we should not just as
women but as people be financially
independent
you know they grew up in their youth
when they were young in London it was
the depression they had to go
throughout those terrible days then they
went through the Second World War
then they went through the post Second
World War so their whole youth that hope
that 20 years of their of their youth
from 20 to 40 was very very difficult
physically financially just really
really tough so to have financial
independence was all-important and they
wanted my sister and I to be teachers
and I did actually trained as a teacher
my sister became a teacher and was a
wonderful teacher her whole life but
that was sort of not my not what I
wanted to do the sort of story of
Hollywood is you know when you hit a
certain age you run out of film roles
that it's become slim pickings you're
the mom then you're the grandmother but
it seems like you have just had this
bountiful I mean obviously completely
you know thank God for all of us that
you have but did you ever come across
that that a dearth of roles after Jane
Tennison or did it just sort of oh no I
don't know it was the opposite actually
honestly my roles became much more
interesting after I hit 40 than they
were before and I think that's still the
case now if you're lucky enough if you
can manage to sort of hang on in there
what I did and I think it was helpful
what was every four years I'd go back at
least three or four years I'd go back to
the theatre because I started off in the
theatre theatre was my my lover my
ambition really was in the theatre and
and I made made sure that I always go
back went back to the theatre and I
think that sort of just helped deepen
the whole my whole career I
somehow and and may people think of me
in a certain way as well
there is such a resolve and strength
each of your characters you know and
isn't something that has come natural to
you in a way because it's just this
presence this determination this quiet
ferocity like that quiet ferocity it's
very nice I like that but no they you
know they as people will always say that
the interesting thing in any role is the
complexity of the character and and the
complexity always comes through their
weaknesses so as what you might call a
strong role is actually a role that's
full of weakness and vulnerabilities and
and ambivalence those are the best roles
that's a strong role you know it's
boring right you want you know we're all
vulnerable complex insecure people all
of us and and you know you want to
that's our job as actors is to reflect
the nature of humanity so you want that
to be as complex as possible I was with
the audience what she wanted Tony for
playing Elizabeth the second you had a
resistance to playing her again but it
was almost like you couldn't say no
right was that I couldn't say no it was
at all of that your favorite amongst
your favorite people and the play was so
brilliant that they were so great no I
went to the read-through
absolutely determined to say at the end
of the read-through we I asked if we
could a reading of the play before we
you know commit it to anything and I
went to the read-through thinking I'm
gonna do the read-through and then I'm
gonna say I'm really sorry but I don't
think this is the right thing for me I
can't do this again
and her character you were on stage for
the only thing for two hours yes
non-stop yes absolutely and I walked in
and there was this amazing team of
people theater people yes you guys
won't probably know but you know Peter
Morgan the writer Stephen Daldry the
director Bob Crowley the designer one of
your favorites
whoa Oh brilliant brilliant designer and
this this was the cream of British
theatre people and I thought and you're
going to walk away from this are you mad
you know so I knew by the end of the
read-through I was going to have to do
it and you said it opened up all these
parts for you you know one of the things
we were just chit-chatting backstage and
Carol when she was mentioning work I've
done I've listened to gender
discrimination in Hollywood with ACLU
and you said God gender and I thought
you've had to field all these questions
so Helen yeah no how do I feel it's
Elizabeth I'm so thrilled that finally
it's in the conversation
women have been having trying to have
this conversation for an awfully long
time
right a very very long time and finally
the conversation is beginning to be
heard and right repeated in the media
and and talked about her I just hope it
continues whatever way you look at it
you're collaborating with the writer and
the producer and the other actors and
everyone the cameraman the light yeah
and and so getting on on the set and I
you know I like a laugh and but
sometimes it's not appropriate but you
know it's very very important to connect
with everybody what is what who's the
unsung here on the set I think the
continuity I couldn't best do that job
you